Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and today, we are back with another iPhone X video, I know what you're saying Justine
it's been at least two or three days since you've last posted a video about your iPhone. We know we get it,
you've got one, but guess what else I've got. Today, I've got some friends.
We have got the Samsung Note 8 and the Google Pixel 2 and over here
we've got the Sony rx100 mark 5. This is my absolute favorite vlogging camera
so it's gonna be really fun to see how this kind of stands up to these guys and to the iPhone X.
So let's go. Jenna just got the basketball court, we're going to take some pictures, we're gonna get some videos and we'll see what happens.
The first thing we're gonna do is we're gonna take some photos so Jenna, my lovely photo assistant here
my lovely photo assistant, here
I'm coming. Hello. I was playing basketball
So I'm gonna have you take some photos on all of these and then the problem with what we're shooting right now is when I
did the iPhone X camera test it was very overcast which actually was pretty great for shooting on this camera right here this big one
Hello, hi Nick. Hi the first on the phone cameras that proves to be a little bit more difficult. Yeah, but watch this
You think I could make it?
No.
No?
You didn't even hit the backboard
Take a normal picture and also take a portrait mode picture on all of them, yes.
First up we have some photos from the iPhone X with the rear camera. This is the iPhone X rear portrait
this is an example with the blur on, blur off
and back with the blur on again and here you've got them all three side by side with a portrait the normal photo and blur on
Moving on. Here we've got the Note 8 rear camera and then moving on to the Note 8 live focus
Here, they are side by side with the normal and the live focus right next to each other.
Instead of calling the portrait mode, Samsung is calling it the live focus.
Here's those same shots using the Pixel 2 and here we have the Pixel 2 rear portrait as you can see,
it did a really great job of blurring out the background.
Side-by-side normal verse portraits and normal verse portrait yet again.
Throwing in that Sony rx100 point-and-shoot here we have those two shots back to back.
I can't. It's...It's all relative.
Right now we're trying to do an action shot test and Jenna is trying to press the button on all of these cameras at the same time
so we can get the same shot. It's not going so well but we're trying.
Looking at this test after the facts
You know I had really great intentions but I feel like it wasn't executed properly.
All of these phones did a pretty great job at these action shots.
I didn't really spot much motion blur
but of course trying to get all of these shots to match up properly proved to be a little bit difficult.
So right now we're gonna be testing out the front-facing camera
I'm gonna be taking some shots, and I love the Pixel front facing portrait mode. It does a really great job.
Now let me see the front facing on the iPhone X, Pixel 2, and the Note 8.
Which ones do you guys think looks the best?
I did leave out the rx100, but here it is
I felt like the phones did such a really great job that it was kind of hard to throw in this point-and-shoot camera especially since
I feel like the phones did a much better job than the Sony did but here it is for reference.
Everything's reporting think I'm in frame on all of these. Let's just maybe move this this is I'm having fun
I'm not sure
We are now recording with all four cameras. The first one I have
right here, this is the Sony rx100
This is the iPhone X.
This here is the pixel 2
and over here, we've got the Note 8. So let's just walk around a little bit
Spin. Hi Nick.
Hi.
Hello
You're walking around you get some different perspectives here. See what these lens flares look like oh look at that. Can you?
Can you not talk about
Those flares JJ Abrams call me definitely. You're definitely gonna want to use these shots in your next film.
So right now, we're testing out the slow-mo on all of the phones and the rx100
We've got them all at 120 frames a second, so we're gonna test out the slow mode and see what we got and I'm gonna take up the drone.
Let's do it.
She's taking it down
This was such a fun test to do, and I honestly planned on posting this video, Wow like a few weeks ago
But I ran into some problems getting the slow-mo footage off of the Note 8 and the Pixel 2 so here it is
I hope that you guys enjoy it. I look forward to hearing your feedback on which camera you liked the best
I'll put a poll up here at the top on YouTube and you guys can choose which one was your favourites.
Did you like the Pixel 2, the iPhone X the rx100 or the Note 8?